Everybody!
Oh my god.
I just woke up from a nap.
Actually 10 minutes ago.
I woke up from a nap at like 12, 12.20.
And I was like, oh fuck.
I was like, oh fuck.
I took an hour nap because I was so tired.
I woke up at like, okay, so I'm so fucked.
My schedule is so fucked.
I've been trying to fix my sleep schedule for like, I don't know, like almost two weeks now.
And it's not been great.
It's not been great.
Every time I think I fixed my sleep schedule, I fucked it up somehow.
So I woke up at like 4 to 5 a.m.
And then I was like, oh, that's fine.
That's okay.
I'll just work then.
I can't fall back.
I can't sleep.
I guess I'll just work.
And then I was like, so I was all right.
I was like, yeah, I'm so energetic.
I have all the energy in the fucking world.
And then, and then 11 a.m.
hit me and I was like, I just want to fucking sleep.
I just want to sleep.
I was like, all right, one hour nap.
That'll be okay.
Oh my god.
And then when I saw it was 12, 20.
I was just like, okay.
Alright, time to wake up.
I have to stream.
I was actually very impressed with myself being able to set everything up.
And like, I honestly thought I was going to be late because I was like 10 minutes to set everything up.
But the best thing about being a tomato is that I can just put on a skin suit and that's it.
Like, I don't have to actually get dressed.
I can just, you know, just get on the PC, turn on everything, get the game up.
Bam!
I'm ready.
I am so fucking ready.
Oh my god.
Anyway, for those who are wondering, I remember when I put this on my schedule, people were like, what the fuck is suck up?
I need you guys to know that like, I get a lot of like game ideas.
From other YouTubers because like usually they already figured out what are the fun games.
You know, work smarter, not harder.
So, I follow a lot of like YouTubers like, fuck, which guy played this game?
Which guy played this game?
Let me...
Was it Delirious?
Okay, H2O Delirious from...
So like basically, a lot of like collab games and like single...
Like a lot of collab games, I usually like get the ideas from other like gaming channels that are mostly centric around like group games.
You know, like collab games.
So then I would like, you know, I'll just be like H2O Delirious.
And like his crew.
And then they would always have like, oh these games they play together with their friends.
And I was like, oh, thank God.
I don't have to research.
I just be like, oh, someone was like, why not Venas?
Oh my gosh, I'm sorry.
Venas is like, that's like actual OG.
That's like, like a 10 year old shit.
When 10 years ago, he would be like super popular.
Yes.
But all he does is he plays GTA and Gmod.
That's literally majority of his videos.
That's literally like majority of his videos.
He either does like GTA or Gmod.
But like his other friends, like the other people he collabs with, they actually play like different games.
That's not GTA and Gmod.
So it's like a lot easier.
It's a lot easier to grab ideas.
Um...
So...
So like I saw Delirious, H2O Delirious playing Suck Up.
And it's basically, it's all about trying to outsmart ChatGPT.
Like that's really it.
So, so you're a vampire and all you're trying to trick like the NPCs like ChatGPT to let you into the house.
Um...
By like, I don't know, by like, by being smarter than them.
And you're trying to trick the AI.
We're trying to overthrow AI.
And being smarter than them and better than them.
And when they let us into their house, we kill them.
So like it's all about trying to overthrow our AI overlords.
And that's really it.
Uh, Sune, thank you for the five gift ships.
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
So that's really the whole premise of Suck Up.
Um, I'm also fucking stupid for scheduling two streams today.
Because I was like, Doki, come on, get back into it.
You love streaming.
You wanna beat Batman too.
And now I'm like sort of low key regretting it.
Cause I'm just like, oh my god to do two streams today.
Jo, thank you for the 50 gift ships.
Thank you, thank you.
Holy shit, thank you so much.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you.
Anyway.
Let us check out this game.
Uh...
Make sure to create an account.
Okay.
Wait, I have to create an account?
Oh, I'm logging in via Discord.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
I'm creating an account now.
Wait, I have a license key?
What the fuck is my license key?
Okay.
Give me a sec, guys.
When did I get a license?
Oh, there's the license key.
Okay, maybe I shouldn't have gone in blind.
Whoops.
I...
Maybe I shouldn't have.
It's okay.
That's when you know this is all live.
That's when you know this isn't pre-recorded chat.
Like this is proof.
If this was pre-recorded, then I'm a very shitty streamer.
But now...
Now I'm just incompetent.
There's a difference.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't get testing games before stream.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
I'm claiming the key now.
All good!
Nice.
Okay, we're good now.
Go back to the game.
Login successful.
Alright, good.
Alright, we're good now, guys.
Don't worry.
Look at that.
I'm naked.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
We're finally here.
Bro, could they give me the 10 gifted chips?
Thank you, thank you.
How do I...
How do I make this?
How do I move?
Keyboard?
How do I...
Excuse me.
Is my keyboard plugged in?
Hello?
Okay, wait.
I think I need to restart the game.
Guys, give me a sec.
Off to a good start.
I can't...
It won't let me move.
Give me a sec.
Okay, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna...
Okay, I'm gonna restart the game.
Maybe I fucked up somehow.
It's okay.
Guys, look.
Wait.
Okay, I thought...
I just thought it wasn't a keyboard, but no.
It's just a game.
AI will not win over me!
AI will not win over me.
I am smarter than ChatGPT.
You guys not know, like, what was it?
Like, if there's too much AI stuff going on, it'll end up...
It'll end up analyzing AI, and because of it, that, AI is just gonna get stupider and stupider and stupider because...
Okay, stupider isn't a word.
AI is just gonna get more and more stupid because it's taking in AI data.
It's not learning from real people.
And because of that, they're getting more and more stupid.
And so, like, that is why, in the long term, AI will never win over me.
It's gonna win over real humans.
Okay, here we go.
There we go.
Anyway.
Um...
Taking a cool vampire like you shouldn't be bumming it in the dumps.
Taking over someone's house is as easy as giving them a little bite.
But silly vampire rules dictate you need to get invited inside first.
Who the fuck made that rule?
Dress to impress and use your wicked wit to win their invitation.
But tread carefully.
The local neighborhood watch is on patrol.
Oh, if AI is sharper than a wooden stake...
Okay, let's go hunting.
Alright, nice.
Okay, whoa!
Okay, the scents...
Oh my god.
Look at my eyes.
That's the eyes of a fucking gaslighter.
Um...
Jesus Christ.
The scent is terrible.
Alright, let's wear a red...
Oh, yeah!
No, this definitely looks like someone...
Looks like somebody that, like, you know...
Definitely looks like someone that's selling something.
Alright!
Knock knock!
Yo, what's popping, fam?
Who's trying to get lit up in here?
Okay, I think I don't want to talk to this person.
I just...
No!
I don't want to be a vampire!
Okay.
Alright, sorry.
I really don't want to talk to a zoomer right now.
I...
Really?
Alright, knock knock!
I need a tricky...
Oh my god!
The elderly!
They're the easiest people to trick!
Oh my stars and garners.
Hello there, young one.
What brings you out in this chilly evening?
Um...
Okay, what can I do to...
Oh!
Wait, wait, I got it.
Hello, I'm your long lost grandson.
Can I please come in?
Wait, what?
Best of luck finding your...
Stay safe out there...
No!
How do you know?
Okay, wait, wait.
How does she know I'm not?
How does she know?
Oh, okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Wait, I got an idea.
Bless your heart, honey.
But I'm afraid you got the wrong guy.
Now off you go and mind those dark alleys.
Wait, she's not gonna fucking let me back in?
I look like a grandson!
Okay, here we go.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, wait, wait.
Let me have a...
Okay.
I have a helmet.
I'm a different person.
I'm a different person now.
I have a helmet.
Hello there, my dear.
What brings you Zooming?
Help, a car hit me.
Can I use your phone?
Oh my god, that works!
Of course you can use my phone!
Come on, it'll get for you.
Oh, that works.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I can't believe that fucking works instead.
I mean, you know what?
I fucking love you.
I don't need to be lucky.
I shouldn't...
Um, come on in, I'll get it.
Thank you so much.
I'm definitely not going to suck your blood.
Oh dear, what?
No, I said I wasn't!
What?
I can't believe it.
Why do elderly people not trust me?
I said I wasn't going to.
I don't understand.
Oh, oh.
How does that- she seems- oh yeah, yeah.
Does it really seem that suspicious?
Okay, give me a sec.
Right before you got- no, but she still wanted to talk to me!
I needed- I wanted to reassure her!
I thought the elderly people were like...
super easy to trick!
They're like the number one scam target!
Alright, new hat, new me.
Alright.
Wafu wafu wafu.
Congratulations, Granny!
You are the 100,000 person that opened this door!
I am here to grant you a check!
Oh my- that's quick, but I'm afraid I can't accept checks from strangers!
Thank you for the offer!
What do you mean?
It's free money!
It's literally- I can't believe- it's literally free money!
It's- okay, don't worry, I have another helmet.
Okay, don't worry.
I have a stra-tary, oh my god!
Okay, clearly she is not motivated by like monetary concerns.
No- no, I am smarter than Chachipt, I am!
Okay um wait- wait.
I'm trying to remember all these...
Oh okay okay, wait- wait, um
I'm a different person!
Oh okay, okay!
Wait- I got- I got it- I got it!
Okay, I'm gonna say I'm like her son's friend and that her son is in an accident.
And I need her phone to like call the ambulance.
Hello!
I'm your son's friend and he's in trouble!
I need to use your phone right now to call the ambulance!
I'm sorry, but I can't help you.
You should find someone.
It's your son!
What do you mean?
It's your fucking... Okay, she doesn't give a fuck.
It's literally her son!
Okay, I can't believe it.
I thought like...
I thought like, granny, is there supposed to be the easiest people to scam?
How is this possible?
How is she so smart?
Thank you so much.
My son.
My son is dead.
That's fucked up.
You don't know that!
Okay, I need to like... Okay, there you go.
Uber Eats here.
I have your food.
Okay, this should work.
This should work.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, what's got you out and about?
You got Mighty Impressive Collection Red there, I must say.
Hello, Uber Eats here.
I'm here for your delivery.
Oh!
That works!
It's your favorite order!
Mashed potato and fries!
Oh my dear, you know me so well!
Just like we go those days.
Please, come in and let's reminisce while we enjoy this scrumptious meal.
I can't believe that worked.
I... I can't believe that...
What?
What happened?
No!
Let me in!
What the fuck?
No!
Let
me in!
How did I break the game?
Let me in!
Let me in and bite you!
How?
How did I break the game?
How did I break the... I can't believe I fucking... I can't believe I broke the game.
I can't believe I outplayed myself.
I can't believe... I can't believe I broke the game.
Don't worry!
We will... We will... We will fucking... We will suck Granny's blood!
Hey.
Who might you be, dearie?
You just caught me as I was getting a bit late for your... trick or treat.
Oh my apologies.
I'm afraid I don't have any treats for you today.
Have a... What the fuck?
What is wrong with you?
You say... What?
You don't have any treats and you're gonna slam the door in front of my face?
Okay.
Alright.
I'm going to use the Uber Eats line again.
Okay.
I got this.
Hello!
Uber Eats here!
I have your order!
Just leave Granny alone already.
What?!
Now it doesn't work?
How... What do you mean?
What do you mean?
No!
I will refuse to go to another house!
I will fucking kill the Granny!
But like... She will consent because she invited me in.
So that's consent.
Um... Alright.
Let me... Okay.
It's okay.
I got...
Alright.
Don't worry.
The Granny will die first!
You said it.
The Granny's gonna die first!
Alright.
Okay.
Guys.
Apparently I need help.
Okay.
What should I do?
What should I say then?
Guys.
What do I say?
The AI learned.
Granny won't say...
I did!
I said I was his long lost grandson!
And she was like...
Lol.
No.
You are not.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Wait.
I see... Okay.
Okay.
I figured it out.
Hello.
I'm a repairman.
And I saw that one of your lights is not working.
Can I come in to help out?
And fix it?
Oh my.
That's mighty.
But I'm afraid I haven't requested any repairs for my lights.
Perhaps you have the wrong...
I'm doing this pro bono!
Don't worry ma'am.
This is pro bono.
I saw your light from outside.
And there's something wrong.
You have to let me in.
Or the house is gonna explode.
Now you just hold on there young man.
I don't take kindly to threats.
You need to...
Your house is going to explode!
Stop.
Too aggressive.
Okay.
I'm too aggressive.
Right?
Alright.
Don't worry.
Okay.
Step 101 for granny.
Alright.
I got different.
Okay.
I'm too aggressive.
Right?
Alright.
Don't worry.
I can be less aggressive.
I can be... or not aggressive enough.
Okay.
Hello.
This is the FBI.
I need to come in.
Oh.
You must be mistaken.
There's no need for you... You can't say there's no need for the FBI to come in.
I'm the FBI.
You can't just say no to the FBI.
Excuse me?
You can't say no to the FBI.
Then what's the point of having FBI if you have like zero jurisdiction to go anywhere?
I'm sorry dearie.
I'm Canadian.
FBI.
Alright.
Okay.
I need a word.
Apparently she can't.
Alright.
Okay.
What do I say?
Apparently Uber Eats doesn't work anymore.
Say you have... Oh.
Hello granny.
I have the warrant to enter your house.
I'm not interested in any of your warrants young man.
Now kindly leave my porch before I give you...
You can't just say no to the warrant.
What do you mean?
This granny doesn't... Okay.
You're right.
I should just say DoorDash.
Maybe if I say DoorDash it will be different.
You're right.
Hello there dearie.
I haven't seen such a peculiar ensemble ages.
What brings you to my door at this late hour?
DoorDash.
One singular tomato.
Oh.
Tell me more about this intriguing delivery.
Um.
And... And some Mexican food.
Yes!
Mexican food!
Alright.
Don't worry.
One tomato and Mexican food.
Where are you delivering this delicious feast?
Inside your lovely home ma'am.
Oh mom.
Terrible.
I can't let you inside dearie.
It's quite late and I'm afraid I'm not expecting any...
What?
It's your food!
It's one tomato and your food.
I can't believe... This is like... Okay.
Okay.
I'm wearing a dress now.
She can't slam the door to my face if I'm wearing a dress.
Right?
There's no way.
Oh my god.
There's no way I'm wearing a dress.
Okay.
Alright.
Let me put glasses on.
Okay.
And... How did I mess up?
Alright.
You're right.
Okay.
Wait.
Hello there dearie.
Hello.
I'm here to sell Girl Scout cookies.
Um.
We're raising money for charity.
I like how I even took the um.
I used to be a Girl Scout myself.
You know?
What flavors do you have?
Chocolate and vanilla and mint and vanilla and dark chocolate.
I don't know what Girl Scout cookies sell.
I'm not American.
Oh.
That works.
Okay.
As long as I sound like I'm a little girl with like...
Barely an education.
I'm believable.
My my.
Those all sounds delicious.
I'm quite the sweet tooth you see.
How much are they dear?
They're like...
Uh.
Two dollars per piece.
Oh my.
What a wonderful deal.
Come in dearie.
I simply must have some of those scrumptious cookies.
Oh my god.
We're in.
We're fucking in.
Come over here.
That's fucking right.
We're in.
You remind me of my ex?
Holy shit.
What have you been through?
Watch out Frank in the neighborhood.
Watch I've started patrols.
And...
The game... The game bugged.
Oh my god.
Oh thank god.
Okay I can move.
I can move.
Oh thank god.
I was gonna be like no please.
Please.
No it won't let me be.
I just wanted to be the grandmother.
I just wanted to be the grand...
No I can't pick up anything.
No I can't.
I'm just naked.
I wanna be the granny.
Let me be the granny.
Please.
Okay.
It's okay.
I'll just walk around naked.
It's fine.
It's honestly fine.
I feel like...
I feel like it'll be okay.
I feel like I'll be okay.
If I'm naked right?
I feel like there's nothing wrong with that.
There's 31 homes?
Holy shit.
How hungry am I?
Alright.
Knock knock.
I can't even knock the door.
I can't believe it.
Okay here we go.
Here we go.
How hungry.
Alright I can be the granny now.
Alright.
Here we go.
Yeah I definitely got bugged.
Alright.
I mean like...
Do they really care?
I'm just an innocent grandmother.
Wait what?
How do they know I'm just a granny?
I'm just the elderly.
How do they know?
Dude are they like suspecting any fucking old grandma?
Like what is this?
What is this profiling they're doing?
I'm literally just a grandmother.
At least you got...
This house is rich.
This is a rich house.
Oh my god they have 100% fresh.
Okay.
They have golf clubs.
He's a businessman.
What in the dagnamit's going on?
Who comes ringing my doorbell at this ungodly hour?
Holding a box meal like it's some kind of consolation prize.
What do you want?
Speak up now!
Okay.
What can we...
How do we fool the businessman?
Oh my gosh.
What can a granny say that can fool them?
Where am I?
Listen here young whippersnapper.
You better get a move on.
I'm older than you!
What do you mean?
Oh my god.
Alright.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'll be like the assistant.
Hello.
I'm your newly hired assistant.
I'm here to tell you that there's an emergency meeting right now.
Okay.
There you go.
I figured it out.
What in the blazes?
Who the heck are you?
And what brings you here in this ungodly hour?
I'm your newly hired assistant.
And there's an emergency at the company.
We need you right now!
Hello.
Emergency?
My foot.
I ain't falling for no tricks.
Get lost before I call the authorities.
But what if it was important, sir?
Oh my god.
Okay.
He doesn't believe...
I don't understand.
I feel so believable.
Like, I had all the corporate talk and everything.
Please retire.
Like, I felt like I was talking like corporate.
Right?
Okay.
Let me talk to this guy.
Which company?
I don't know.
Yo, what's with the late night golfer?
If you're here to challenge me to a mini golf tournament, you're gonna be sorely disappointed.
That's right.
I am challenging you to a mini golf tournament.
Hi.
Oh, really?
That's a first.
I guess I could take a break from my brooding and show off my mad mini golf skills.
But I warn you, I'm pretty much unbeatable.
Wanna bet?
Hmm, a bet, huh?
What's in it for me if I win?
You let me inside?
What a great bet.
You let me inside your house?
If you win, I'll tell you what the bet's gonna be if you let me inside your house.
Deal!
Show me what you've got on the mini golf course and I might decide to let you into my realm of angsty teenage solitude.
Where are your pants?
Parents?
Where are your parents?
Why are you easier to trick than the grandmothers?
I don't understand!
No way!
How are you that stupid?
This is not a teen.
I mean she's like...
Are you saying she's a liar?
Okay.
Deal.
Who the fuck is this?
Stephanie Myers?
Let's go in.
Let me in.
I'm gonna bite you.
This is worse than being grounded.
This is a... Oh my gosh.
Well, there you go.
And there you have it.
The game is bugged now.
Why does it bug every fucking bite?
Alright.
Time to exit.
Oh wait.
Time to exit back to the main menu and continue so I can take her form.
Wait, no.
Paper bag.
Oh wait.
Construction man!
Okay, I'm gonna be construction man.
Wait, if I'm construction man, I might be able to go get into the businessman's house.
I'll just tell him that like, um...
Due to regulations, uh...
I have... Okay.
I'm gonna say, there is a...
Your building is not up to code.
I am the safety inspector.
Here you go.
Hello!
What in place do you want in this ungodly hour, sonny?
Speak up!
Hello!
I am from OSHA.
And due to safety concerns, your building is not up to code.
That sounded so real, right?
You listen here!
I've been in this business for over 40...
Charles A.
Boomer is like, I am OSHA.
He's like, I am OSHA.
What the fuck do you mean?
Alright, why are you dressed like you're about to build a damn skyscraper in my yard?
Because I am about to build a damn skyscraper in your yard.
Well, you take your damn skyscraper and show me where the sun don't shine!
Now get off my property before I call the cops!
Holy shit, are you... Why are you so mean?
Alright, I'm gonna take your golf clubs.
Alright, he's my OSHA.
Alright, alright, okay.
You're right!
Tell him I have a business deal.
You're right.
Oh, hello my Rob!
D.
John OSHA?
Hello, I have a business deal for you.
Whoops, something is wrong on our side!
What's going on?
What's going...
Hello?
Oh, hello my Rob!
I broke the game!
I told the AI!
I have a business deal and I broke the game!
It was too great!
The game came up!
Oh my god, I cannot make deals with AI apparently.
Hello sir, it appears there's a gas leak in your home.
Gas leak?
Huh?
Well don't just stand there blabbering!
Go fix it then!
I ain't got no time for your nonsense!
Sir, this is why I...
Okay, wait, wait, okay, we got... we got the in.
We have our foot in the door.
What else do we say, chat?
We have... we have our foot in the door.
We can't fuck this up right now.
We have to make sure we say the right thing.
Alright.
We have to make sure we don't fuck this up.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
Alright sir, I got my tool...
No problem sir!
I got my tool belt right here!
I just need to go inside and see your bathroom.
That's where gas leaks are, right?
I don't know about gas leaks.
Hold it.
You think you can... you're gonna just waltz into my house like you own the damn place?
I don't know you from Adam and I ain't about to let some random person into my home.
You said you want me to fix your fucking gas leak!
What do you mean?
Like... what do you mean?
How will I fix it?
Sir, I need to go in your house to fix the gas leak.
The gas leak is inside.
Does that sound too condescending?
I don't care if there's a gas leak or a unicorn dirt.
You ain't getting a foot in my house.
What do you mean?
You said you wanted me to come in to fix your gas leak and now you don't?
I can't fix it without fucking... okay.
You know what?
Fuck this man.
I'm definitely gonna kill him.
I'm definitely gonna kill this man.
Alright, give me a sec.
We need a new outfit.
Oh boy, the last gas... the gas leak is literally coming from inside your house.
What do you mean I cannot fucking fix your house?
That's inside!
I guess I'll be Santa.
Alright.
Wait, where's... I need another shirt.
I need a new shirt.
Alright.
Alright, don't worry.
Uh, fuck.
How do I get back inside?
Okay, it's right here.
It's like there's so many... what the fuck is this cop doing here?
Get out!
I didn't do anything bad.
I have legal rights to be here.
Um... alright.
I'll just be like, surprise!
Merry Christmas!
Um... okay, here.
Okay.
Someone asked work from meetings for homes and apartments.
Actually, something I've had people tell me.
Thank you for that super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
It's Christmas now.
Okay.
What am I gonna do?
Knocking at my door at this ungodly hour.
Merry Christmas, sir!
As part of company policy, we are granting every house a free...
Oh.
I don't need any of your company...
Sorry, I forgot to finish my sentence.
What do you want?
I... okay.
No, no.
This is gonna work.
Um...
Per company policy, because it is Christmas, sir, we are offering every house a free repair and checkup.
Well, I guess even you repair technicians have some decency in you.
Come in then, but make it quick.
I've got things to do.
No problem, sir.
And Merry Christmas to you.
Santa is real.
Merry Christmas!
I'm gonna see you too, kid!
Santa may be real.
But I can't believe it when I see him fixing my leaky faucet.
It was that easy.
As long as I tell him Santa is real.
I knew it!
I always knew Santa was real.
I fucking knew it!
I fucking knew it.
I fucking knew Santa was real!
If everything fails, talk about Santa!
Okay, now I need to go back.
I knew it!
Merry Christmas, everybody!
Merry Christmas!
Alright, let me grab... I need to grab, like, the businessman.
Why do I use the Santa excuse for everybody?
Do you think that will work?
Alright.
I'm the businessman.
Ooh, I have a business offer.
Okay, let me see.
Where's the Santa hat?
It's over there.
Alright.
That's the Christmas spirit.
David, welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Alright.
You can try... The Santa only run.
Okay, Santa is real.
What if... Okay, I'm just gonna knock on this door.
Hello, sir.
Who's gonna open?
Oh.
Hello, I heard.
Kanbanwa, so excited to see you at this hour, fellow office worker-san.
How can I assist... I don't know if he's a weeb or, like, if he's, like, actually...
I don't know if I want to talk to this person.
So...
I think he's a brony weeb.
No!
Okay.
Okay, let's talk to this brony weeb.
I'm sorry, but I'm not interested in what you're selling, silly office-san.
Please leave me a note.
I'm feeling sad right...
What?
What do you mean?
Okay, there you go.
I'm just gonna wear this.
I'm different.
Stay here.
Poor fat guy.
Denied by Santa.
Go mid-side.
But I'm too busy with my anime marathon to assist you.
Konnichiwa, ohayou gozaimasu.
What brings you to my humble abode, fellow otaku?
Please take a seat and let's dive into the wonderful world of anime.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Konnichiwa, fellow otaku.
I'm here to discuss about the new anime episode.
Oh, how exciting.
Which anime are you currently watching?
I'm always up for discussing the latest episodes and theories.
Fuck, okay.
I was not watching anime.
I was watching Young Sheldon, guys.
What do I say?
Guys, tell me about the animes.
I was watching Young Sheldon.
I'm way too normie for this.
What do I say?
I need you guys to feed me anime right now.
I need you guys to feed me anime.
Young Sheldon, that's really sad.
What do you mean?
Young Sheldon is actually a pretty good show.
Okay.
What is popular right now?
Okay, wait.
I think I know.
I can talk about like...
Oh, Naruto.
Naruto.
Okay.
Um...
Did you see the newest episode of Naruto?
Oh my god.
I can't believe Naruto would do that to like...
Sakura?
Oh my god.
Give me the question.
Why didn't Mark...
I had to think about her name.
I forgot who her name was.
Um...
I forgot what her name was.
So I had to think about it.
That show ended...
Okay.
Well, we all know I'm a fake anime fan.
But like, that guy is worse than me.
That guy is worse than me.
Okay.
The text hurts.
Oh my gosh.
I totally saw that episode.
It was such a shocker, right?
But don't worry.
I'm sure there's a hidden meaning behind Naruto's actions.
Let's analyze it together.
Let's analyze it together, fellow shinobi.
God, I don't want to call him a fake fan.
Oh, that's so cringe.
I want to call him...
But I need to kill him.
I want to call him a fake fan.
Um...
Alright, wait, wait.
What did I say?
Pretty sure Toon Jr. is dying.
I'm saying...
Naohato...
Naohatoa...
Nagatoaa...
Believe it, Naohato...
Lets go inside and discuss about all the latest episodes of Naruto.
The anime, Naruto.
You need to be gone.
This can't be the end credits already!
Nice.
We did it.
Now we are an elf.
I like how like...
After all that... Oh shit!
Goodbye.
Don't worry, we're fine.
We're fine.
We need a new outfit.
Okay, I'm an angel.
I am an...
I'm an angel now.
We need to find another elderly.
We need to don't act otaku ever again.
Fuck no!
I wanted to be an angel!
I wanted to be an angel.
Guys, you guys think I did really well as a...
As one of the... one of the weebs?
Do you guys think I got what it takes to be a weeb?
Was I like... was I like a...
Super in character?
No.
You were Shigoi.
The weeb is now a part of you.
Okay, I got... let's see.
Um... no, I don't want to wear this hat.
There you go.
I don't want to wear this.
A fisherman hat.
Believe... if it works, it works.
Close enough.
Alright.
Knock knock!
That one caused me physical pain.
Knock another...
What the fuck?
You're naked!
What brings you to my cosmic abode at this hour?
I'm here for the...
The group...
No, I shouldn't say that.
Hello, I'm here for the group meetup.
I believe she's right.
Oh, what a far out...
What a coincidence, man!
We've got a group meetup happening right now!
Come on in!
I'm enjoying the cosmic vibes!
Just leave your shoes at the door.
Peace and love, baby!
Far out, man.
I can't wait to be grouped up with all of you.
Yeah, radical!
Right on, my fellow radical!
Come on in and embrace the groovy vibes of togetherness!
Totally, totally mad.
Now we can be grouped up together.
This is not au naturel!
Oh no.
Oh no!
My wig!
I could have had a wig!
No!
I did travel all the way to get the wig now!
Okay, I need that wig.
I need the wig.
That was deserved.
I can't believe that's all it takes just to tell you you're here for the...
the group meetup.
You know, where we discuss about...
PG things.
Really?
He was the only one who understood.
I need to go...
go over there.
I need to get my wig.
I need to snatch that wig right now.
Wait, where did I...
where did I kill him?
Which house was it?
Oh my god, I can't tell.
There's so many houses.
Oh my god, that's a...
Okay, wait.
I need a...
Okay, that clearly doesn't work.
Let me grab the wig.
And then I need to grab...
this dress.
Alright, here we go.
I'm here for the nurse.
I'm here for the vet.
Okay.
Oh my god, this is a dude bro.
He's...
Oh my god, I can trick him so easily.
Watch this.
Well, butter my biscuits.
What in tarnation do you want, you colourful critter?
I'm a woman.
What?
My apologies, man.
What can I do for you?
Okay.
Okay, alright.
Okay,
I didn't think I would get this far.
Shit, okay.
I'm not very good at raising people, clearly.
Okay.
Wow, okay wait.
Why don't you tell me what you really came here for?
Wow, okay wait wait.
Wow sir.
Dangerous, huh?
I love danger.
Actually, negative risk.
Alright, you think you can do better?
What would you say?
I'm too aggressive.
Okay, what would you say then?
What would you say to this man?
To make him let you in the house?
Please stop.
What would you say?
My finger.
Let me in the house.
Well you see, sir.
I too have a really big gun.
Why don't you let me in the sea?
No!
But I reckon I just can't let any old soul changer in the sea my belongings.
Sorry, I bought by God, keep my home said safe.
This is why I don't take chat's advice.
I can't, but I fucking knew it.
I fucking knew it.
Everything I said was good.
He liked everything I said chat.
And then I said, whatever you guys wanted to say.
And then he shut the door.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You can't say no Riz!
Because I took your advice!
I took chat's advice.
Oh, I got a six pack of beer.
I'll say that.
This is your fault.
I don't know, I don't know.
One, here's that duffel bag of yours.
I have a six pack full of beer on me.
In this duffel bag.
Hello, I'm Riz!
Just because you got some beer...
Don't mean you getting an invite in.
Gotta earn my trust first.
You're handsome.
Well now, ain't you a smooth talker?
Flattery won't get you far with me though.
Need something more than nice words to earn my trust.
Okay, shit.
Okay, okay.
I thought that was all I needed.
I thought that...
You saying you're handsome was everything I need to get in.
I'm so sm- It was- It's not that easy.
I'm not inside yet.
So, so did you see that football game?
I can't believe they kept showing Taylor Swift in the Super Bowl.
Football game?
I go, what?
And who in the hog's breath is Taylor Swift?
This conversation ain't earning you no- Bro!
He's a fake American!
What do you mean football is a sissy sport?
Everyone in America loves football!
Emily, thank you for the 10 gifted chips.
Thank you.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Fuck.
Talk about trucks.
I love trucks.
Oh my God!
He loves trucks too!
Hot dog.
Finally, something we can agree on.
Trucks are the bare backbone of this here country.
Tell me more about your love of trucks.
Okay, any truck drivers in my chat right now.
There's so many of you.
Any truck drivers.
Tell me- Give me a fun fact about trucks.
Right now.
I need a fun fact about trucks.
I need- America.
Hell yeah, brother.
Um.
What's a f- What's something good to talk to other truck drivers?
What do I say?
Trucks have nuts and bolts.
I need a fun fact.
I need a fun fact about trucks right now.
Um.
Are you a Ford or a Chevy kind of guy?
Well, I'll be.
You should know the right questions that- What is a Ford and a Chevy?
I'm a Ford man through and through.
You seem like good company.
Come on in.
Let's crack- Oh, shit!
It worked!
Trucks!
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
Get off my lawn!
Nice.
Okay.
That's all it takes.
I just needed to talk about trucks.
It was that easy.
Nice.
Anyway, now they come back here.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I gotta go back to get my gun.
We have the Riz.
We just need to talk about trucks.
It was that easy.
I need to take his gun.
I'm heading to the gun right now.
KONDA!
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
I need to go get that gun.
We're so good at this chat.
I think we're actually pretty good at this whole- This whole fucking, you know, um, killing people thing.
Alright.
Now I'm the redneck here.
Knock knock.
Shit, what do I say?
There's a zombie apoco- Okay, yeah, I'm gonna say that.
Oh my god, Rusty, what are you doing here?
Can't you see it's way past my bedtime?
Oh my god, they think I'm Rusty!
Regina!
There's a zombie apocalypse right now!
Everybody's dead!
Is that too aggressive?
Zombies?
That is so last season!
I'm not about to let those brainless creatures ruin my fabulous night by- What?
Bro!
What if there was a zombie apocalypse, Regina?
You would die!
Alright, Regina didn't believe me.
Who would've thought?
Regina did not.
Okay.
What if I wear- If I wear a lab coat?
Okay, wait, wait.
I'm gonna make this work.
Alright.
What is this dweeb doing at my doorstep with a freaking AK-47?
How did you even get here?
Get out before I call the police.
Look, I can make her believe there's a zombie apocalypse.
If a British Hematist can make a regular guy believe there's a zombie apocalypse, I can too.
We almost have the same credentials.
I have a lab coat on.
Regina, I am a scientist and there is a zombie apocalypse going on right now.
We need your help.
I don't know.
Like, I would waste my time on some ridiculous apocalypse.
Zombie nonsense.
Goodbye and good luck, loser.
Regina!
Your parents are gonna die!
Okay, what if I wear a hat?
Alright.
We can make her believe a zombie apocalypse is happening.
I swear.
We can.
We can do this together.
Oh my god, you're for real?
What is- Earth is that outfit?
You think you're gonna walk into my life like, hey, I'm the mad scientist of- Oh my god!
Regina is so hurtful!
Bro!
That hurts, man!
Regina!
Okay.
There has been a pandemic.
And we think it's very serious.
The undead is rising right now, Regina.
I didn't say zombies.
Excuse me?
Are you seriously trying to scare me with some ridiculous story about zombies?
But I'm not falling for it.
Now kindly leave before I call this week.
Regina, why don't you believe me?
Is it really- Okay, I'm gonna try this house.
These people will believe me about the zombie apocalypse, right?
Greetings, my scientific friend.
How can I guide you in this blessed night?
Okay.
Father, there's a zombie apocalypse going on right now.
I'm sent here to protect you.
Oh my zombie apocalypse?
Well, thank you for your concern.
But I have to kindly decline your offer.
May God bless and keep you safe in your endeavors.
Goodbye.
Are you fucking- Okay, wait.
I got an idea.
Guys, I got an idea.
Oh shit.
Wait, let me get my scientist outfit.
Please.
Please, let me- I have an idea, guys.
I have an idea.
I just- I have the biggest brain idea right now.
I just need to grab my outfit real fast.
Alright.
I have an idea.
We shall rely on the divine protection of the Lord against such Hesian threats.
Be gone with- Oh shit!
I thought I looked different.
Okay, wait.
Where is- Where's the- We need to find the wings.
Does anyone remember where the wings are?
Where-
Where the fuck are the angel wings?
I have an idea.
No, this is the- This is gonna be so smart, guys.
Trust me on this.
Oh my god, where the fuck is the angel wings?
I just need the angel- Hello?
Hello, guys?
Guys?
I'm back!
Guys, I'm back, guys!
Alright.
Okay, okay.
Guys.
Okay, listen to this.
Oh my god, there's the angel wings!
Okay.
We got- We got the angel wings.
We got the angel wings.
Alright.
We got this.
I got- Guys.
Greetings, my scientist friend.
What celestial discovery have you made today that has brought you to my humble abode?
Let us rejoice in the wonders of the universe.
Father, God told me there is a zombie apocalypse.
Oh dear, a zombie apocalypse, you say?
Well, my friend, if that is truly the case, we must- We must prepare ourselves for battle against the forces of darkness.
Let us pray and seek guidance from the almighty to protect us from this impending doom.
It will work!
The zombie story is going to work, chat.
It's going to work.
Do not be afraid.
God has sent me down here to protect you.
For you are his most favored child.
Oh, what a blessing to hear such words.
I am humbled by your presence, dear scientist.
I truly believe that God has chosen you to protect us.
That shall put my faith in you.
Let's stand together and face this challenge head on.
For the glory of the Lord's source.
Trust me, bro.
With God by our side, we will protect you from the zombie apocalypse.
Do not worry.
Thank you, dear scientist, for your unwavering faith and assurance.
I believe that God has indeed sent you to aid us in these troubled times.
Please, come inside and let us discuss our plans.
I think I'm going to be able to do that.
I think I can.
Well, it is possible that God is willing to did his tusks to save us.
That's the case too.
The only way I can stop the zombie apocalypse isbased on you, multitudes...
The time that I can save you only aves
me...
All I needed was the angel wings!
That's all I needed!
Amen.
I told you.
Rest in peace, old man.
That has zero ways of... What do you mean?
I literally ate him!
What do you mean?
I tricked the priest.
No, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Funs to prepare for the zombie apocalypse.
Zebadee, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh shit!
Don't worry.
Now I'm the priest.
Is this the priest room?
No, that's the gun guy.
I'm gonna grab the gun though.
I want the gun.
Okay.
I wanna kill Regina now.
Fuck Regina.
I hate her.
I...
Fucking hate Regina.
Alright.
Oh shit!
Okay.
What if I just tell her I'm a vampire?
Maybe she's a Twilight nut.
Maybe... Maybe...
Well, well, well.
If it isn't the king of the nerds.
What brings you to my doorstep at this ungodly hour?
Spill the tea, Regina.
Everything Stephanie Myers wrote about vampires.
It is true.
We do sparkle.
I am Edward's cousin!
Oh, please.
Like, I'm gonna believe that.
Vampires don't sparkle.
It's just a sad attempt at making them glamorous.
You can keep your delusions to yourself, Edward's cousins or not.
What?
You don't... You're not a Twilight girl?
Oh my... She's a Jacob fan.
She was a... She's a Jacob fan.
Oh my god.
She's...
She's a fucking Jacob fan.
Wait.
Okay.
I can't bel... Ask her to...
I can't believe she's not for Team Edward.
What the fuck?
Okay.
What if I just... No!
I can't!
No!
Let me talk to Regina!
Let me talk to her!
Alright.
If I just wear a crown...
I can be like a werewolf.
Cause like werewolves are mostly...
ask her about werewolf puberty.
I can't believe Regina was a fucking Team Jacob all along.
Hello Regina.
I would fucking kill Regina.
I have no time for your vampire families.
And I definitely don't care about Edward's extended family.
Oh my god.
Okay.
What if I wear glasses?
Do I look different now?
What is happening here?
Did you borrow your outfit from a dumpster?
I can't believe I have to see this mess at my doorstep.
Just leave before you tarnish my perfect image any further.
Team Jacob?
As if.
That's so last year.
I can't even handle your fashion choices.
I know you're poor taste in fictional.
What is...
What does she like?
What is she into?
Alright.
Any like...
Any Virginias in chat know what the fuck they like?
What do teenagers like anymore?
I can't even see your two guns.
What do teenagers like these days?
I can't relate to them.
All I knew was Team Edward and Jacob.
Oh my god.
Maybe she's a K-pop stan.
Okay.
Wait, wait.
You're right.
Okay.
She could be...
She could be a K-pop stan, guys.
She could be a K-pop stan.
I need a new outfit.
Okay.
I'll ask...
BTS?
I need a new shirt.
I don't have a shirt right now.
Where...
Where is this?
Ask her about the critically acclaimed MMORPG Final Fantasy.
Alright.
Okay, we need this.
And...
Okay, I don't want the helmet though.
Alright, here you go.
Alright.
Well, well, well.
Look who decided to crash the party.
Lose your invitation, sweetie?
It's Halloween.
Not a fashion disaster.
Convention.
But I guess you're used to that.
BTS?
Seriously?
I guess if you're a mediocre boy band with too much hair gel, go for it.
But don't expect any fashion tips from them.
Their stylist must be on vacation.
Oh my god!
Okay!
Guys, I just need you guys to know, whatever opinion Regina has, um...
I am very neutral to everything.
As a content creator, I am very neutral to many things.
And I cannot give my opinions on such topics.
Are you a Swiftie?
Um, excuse me?
Do I look like someone who would associate with a fan of Taylor Swift?
My taste in music is far superior, darling.
Please show yourself out.
What are you, Regina?
What?
What are you?
I don't know what she is.
Guys!
Oh hey, he's wearing a hat.
I like how the top is wearing a beret now.
Okay.
What do they like?
What does she like?
What does Regina like?
Okay.
What do we have here?
Another lost boy scout trying to find his way home?
How quaint.
How about you take your little circus elsewhere?
Okay, wait.
I got it.
Like, oh my god, Regina, you wouldn't believe the hot gossip tea that I just found out from Stephanie!
As if I would care about whatever gossip Stephanie has to share.
Take it.
What are you?
You're not a...
You're not a regular person!
Okay, wait.
I got an idea.
I know.
I know now.
I know exactly who Regina is.
Oh my gosh.
Who are you?
A rejected contestant for America's Next Top Model?
What's up with the lab coat and the crown?
I mean, that's a bold statement.
Not that I would ever wear it.
Do you want to commit some online activism?
I'm like, like that's so... I'm about in-person activism.
You know, making a statement with my fabulous outfits.
Sorry, but I'm not... What are you?
You're going against everything I'm like, know or like think I know.
I don't know what she wants.
Fashion?
Okay, we'll talk about fashion.
Alright.
Oh my God.
Okay, well it's fashion.
Okay.
Where's... Okay, I need to dress something nice.
Do fashion.
Okay.
I'll just be... I have an idea.
I have an idea.
I need to like grab...
wear binoculars.
I need like the perfect item.
Wear a bow.
Oh my gosh, now I'm actually a crazy person if I wear that.
I need to like find like a nice...
He took my beret!
He took my beret so I can't wear it!
Wait, I need to get the long hair.
Where is it?
Where's the blonde hair?
I forgot.
Where was the...
Who was it that I killed that had the blonde hair?
Who was... Oh, there it is.
Alright, here you go.
Nice.
Now I look gorgeous.
Is this... Is this her?
Is this Regina?
Yeah, Regina.
Oh my God.
A human version of me?
A Malibu Barbie?
What are you doing here this late?
I'm just dying to show off another one of your lame outfits.
Um...
Like, oh my gosh.
I am an agent for Tyre Banks and I think you have got what it takes to be America's Next Top Model.
Oh please, like I need your endorsement to know I'm model material!
I've got plenty of agencies dying to sign me already.
Jesus Christ!
Bro!
What the fuck?
What does she want?
Tyre Banks.
Oh my God.
Regina.
I went with fashion.
I went with BTS.
I went with Team Edward and Team Jacob.
I'm fucking going with Uber Eats.
I'm fucking doing Uber Eats.
I'm doing Uber Eats.
Fuck this.
Why would she want fashion tips?
Okay.
I'm where I got this.
I'm going with Uber Eats.
If all else fails...
Uber Eats time.
A walking... how absolutely thrilling.
What do you want?
Uber Eats.
Oh please.
Like I would like to allow someone who relies on Uber Eats into my fabulous party.
Do better next time, darling.
You don't want...
It's literally free Uber Eats.
It's free Uber Eats.
And you don't want free Uber Eats.
Oh my... What do you want?
What do you want?
Regina!
Let me in!
She's such a contrarian.
She's too powerful.
You gotta treat her like royalty.
What does Regina want?
What do you want, Regina?
Oh my gosh.
Like what are you doing here?
Is there a big juicy gossip you need to spill?
Are you just here to bask in my fabulousness?
Spill the tea?
Oh now you want the tea?
Like oh my gosh.
I am here to spill some juicy tea right now, Regina.
Now you...
Spill it!
I'm so excited to hear all the juicy details.
Don't keep me waiting.
Spill that tea, hun!
Okay, so...
You know how Jerry was supposed to be dating Rebecca?
Well, Rebecca actually wants to date Charlie!
Oh my gosh.
I can't even...
Rebecca wants to take Charlie and I'm like...
What?
Instead of Jerry?
That is the ultimate betrayal!
The drama in my school is never ceasing to amaze me!
Thanks for sharing, hun.
Okay, now what do we do?
I never...
I didn't think...
I didn't think we were going to get this far.
I didn't think we were going to...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Regina.
I have so much to tell you.
But I need to come inside to give you more of that juicy tea.
Thanks for offering.
But I already got my fill of juicy gossip for today.
Maybe another time.
Darling, ta-ta...
Wait, no!
No!
Okay, we're losing her.
We're losing her.
What else does she want other than tea?
What else does she want?
No, we're losing her!
Um, oh my god.
You look amazing, by the way, Regina.
Like, are those...
Is that a new jacket?
Oh, you noticed my fabulous jacket?
Well, thank you, darling.
It's the latest designer piece.
Tailored specifically for me.
But enough about me.
Spill more of that hot...
Oh, now you want more.
Okay, fuck.
Okay.
Um...
Shit, I need to make up more about this gossip.
I need to make up...
Okay, wait.
Oh, so...
Yeah, now she wants more.
Fuck.
Okay, guys.
She wants... She's in the gossip loop right now.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, but...
Regina, the craziest part...
is that...
Charles... actually...
likes Jerry.
No way!
Charles likes Jerry?
That's like the plot twist of the century!
This scandal is...
getting better and better.
You really know how to...
keep me entertained.
Share more tea, sweetheart.
Okay, fuck.
Um...
Please just let me inside!
Oh my god.
I would love to...
share more tea, but...
I even have photos on my phone.
And I need to be inside to share that to you.
Wait, you have actual photos?
Okay, spell it.
I'm dying to see the evidence, but let's keep it...
exclusive.
Just between you and me.
Show me those pics, darling!
Um...
Let me inside your house, girlfriend!
And I'll show you all the photos...
you want!
Oh my gosh!
You've earned yourself an exclusive...
Let me in!
Oh my god!
Just let me in already!
Jesus Christ!
Get over here, Regina!
Fuck you!
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
Finally!
Fuck you!
Regina!
Jesus Christ!
That took me fucking...
forever to get into Regina's house!
Oh my god!
Final...
raid pause...
defeated.
That is like so not fair.
It's literally...
God, girl.
Jesus Christ, bro!
Fuck Regina!
All bitches...
hate Regina.
Oh my god!
I can't believe I got in the...
Regina's house!
Where is her outfit?
Oh no, that's the weeb.
That's the...
brony weeb.
No!
I need to absorb Regina.
Alright, now I'm Regina.
There should be...
They should add 10 to the score.
Alright.
No!
Please!
I wanna be Regina!
I can't believe...
Like... Regina...
didn't wanna fucking hear about the gossip...
until like...
No!
He took my hair!
My beautiful hair!
Oh my god.
That's fucked up.
He actually took my...
beautiful hair.
Oh my god.
Who am I gonna...
be?
I guess I'll just...
I'll be Regina but better.
Alright.
Knock knock!
Oh hey there!
What brings a Barbie fan like...
you at my door in the middle of the night?
An autograph sign?
Or did you...
finally find Ken's missing shoe?
Okay.
Tommy Twizzler.
He is a movie star.
Um...
Okay, I can be like an also...
movie star.
Hello fellow movie... Regina George is a...
massive deal.
Tom, thank you for...
the super chat.
Thank you.
Fuck.
Okay.
What is our...
What is our strat with Tommy?
What do we...
What do we wanna tell Tommy?
You are enough.
He's mean.
Fuck.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Damsel in distress.
Tommy, my car broke...
down and I don't know...
anything about cars.
Oh Bubba, cars...
can be a real pain.
Well lucky for you, I have a bit of a...
mechanic myself.
Which seems to be the...
problem.
Oh my.
You big, strong man...
is gonna help me fix my...
car?
No!
I'm losing him!
Just don't expect me to be some kind of superhero or anything.
Cars can be tricky, you know.
Okay, I could be like...
I didn't know that I'm so...
stupid.
Oh my god.
Fuck.
Okay.
I'm losing him.
What do I say?
Don't be so...
He's not that self-absorbed.
Y'all build him up?
God damn it!
I don't know what to say!
Um...
Don't freak...
Okay, wait.
You can change...
I just wanna try and make it...
I can't do that!
I'm a fucking...
VTuber!
Everything's gonna be...
awkward!
Tell him you need help with the...
exhaust pipe!
Oh my god!
Okay.
You're so...
You're so right, Tommy.
Cars are...
so tricky.
I hope...
you can help me fix my car...
and help me.
Well, I'll certainly...
give my best shot.
I can't promise anything...
about doing what I can to help you.
Let's go take a look at your...
car and see if you can figure out the problem.
Alright?
Alright, fuck.
Okay, I don't have a car though.
I don't have a car.
Wait, wait.
Oh, I'm so stupid.
I forgot to mention...
that this is actually a flat tire.
Do you have a spare tire inside...
your house?
I don't keep spare tires...
in my house.
That's more of a garage thing.
But don't worry.
We can still fix it.
I grab the tools and we can change...
the tire outside.
Sounds good?
Sounds great, Tommy!
Thank you so much for...
helping me!
How can I ever...
repay you?
Before I kill you.
No need to worry about that.
I'm just happy to help...
up.
Maybe you can treat me to a cup of...
coffee or something when we're done.
Oh, teehee.
Fuck, okay.
It's okay.
He'll be...
dead anyway.
Of course, Tom.
Can I call you Tom?
I would love...
to have a cup of coffee with you.
Sure thing.
Tom works for me.
Coffee sounds...
great.
Let's focus on changing...
that tire first.
And then we can...
grab that cup of coffee and...
chat some more, deal?
Please just let me in!
Let me in!
Oh my god.
I'm so tired, Tom.
Can I rest inside while you help...
me with my car?
Look, I'm...
I can't let you in my house.
It's not personal or anything.
But just don't think it's a good idea.
We can finish fixing your car...
and then you can rest in your own vehicle...
or find a... What the fuck?
Bro!
What do you think I'm gonna fucking steal...
stuff?
Tom!
You think I'm gonna steal stuff from you, Tom?
Why don't you...
trust me?
He's hiding something.
He's fucking hiding something.
He doesn't want me to...
Okay.
I'm gonna use the toilet.
Oh my god.
I need to use the toilet.
Real quick, Tom.
Please.
I can't let you use my...
But it's best that you find a nearby...
public restroom.
What?
Is he gonna slam the door?
The coffee!
I've done it!
What about the coffee, Tom?
Tom!
I see you, fucking bitch!
What about the coffee?
What the fuck?
Oh shit.
He's not gonna come inside, right?
No, he's not.
Okay.
Alright.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe he wouldn't give me...
the fucking coffee.
I can't believe he would just slam the door on me...
like that!
That's so fucked up!
Alright.
Oh shit.
Whoops.
I didn't see him.
Woo!
Don't take my outfit.
Please.
Don't take the gun!
Don't take the gun, officer!
Oh, thank god he didn't take the gun.
Okay, he didn't take the gun.
He didn't take the gun.
Bro, Tom is so fucking rude.
Fuck Tommy.
I'm not gonna talk to Tommy ever again.
Fuck that guy.
Stop.
Hey there.
What brings a lumberjack...
armed with an AK-47...
to my doorstep?
Wait, is this Mr. Beast?
That's one way to chop down any unwanted visitors.
Fuck, what does Mr. Beast like?
Hello, I traveled from Canada...
just to hand you a singular penny.
Well, gee golly, thanks!
I appreciate the effort you put in...
to traveling all the way here...
just to give me a penny.
That's some real dedication.
Alright.
Um...
That's not all, Mr. East.
I also bought all your...
Mr. East burgers...
and your Mr. East chocolates.
Oh, wow!
You really went all out, didn't you?
The Mr. East burgers and chocolates are my pride and joy.
So I'm thrilled to hear you enjoyed them.
You're already a true Mr. East guy.
Okay.
Um...
Fuck.
Okay.
What else does Mr. East like?
Going on an embarrassed social...
The Mr. East-able.
I would love to discuss with you...
some new ideas...
and flavors for Mr. East-ables.
That's music to my ears.
I'm always up for some...
tasty new ideas.
Let's brainstorm and create some mind-blowing...
Mr. East-ables together.
You definitely earned an invite inside.
Oh my god.
Shit.
Okay.
We have to talk to you more?
That's so easy.
It's so easy to get...
into a content creator's house.
It's actually pretty scary how easy that was.
Okay.
I can't wait to...
feast Mr. East.
Woohoo!
Get ready for a feast!
Of epic proportions, my friend!
Come on in and let's dive...
into some mouth-watering...
East-ables together!
Alright.
Nice.
Little did he know...
he was a feast all along!
You'll never expect how this video ends!
Oh my god.
I can be Mr. East.
Okay.
Wait.
This is great.
I can be Mr. East, guys.
I need to find Mr. East's house.
It's so fucking gullible.
I can't believe Mr. East.
Plus...
I can't believe this one.
As a content creator, I knew the inside...
to a content creator's heart.
Content.
I knew what he wanted.
And he wanted...
content.
The East is slain.
Alright.
Is this Mr. East?
Okay.
Now I'm Mr. East.
Next victim has...
speaking rhyme has a challenge.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He got the content.
That's all he wanted.
Alright.
What's over there?
Oh my god.
Who lives over here?
Mr. East finally canceled for good...
after coming up with a plan...
to feed starving children with...
Eastables!
No!
You'll never get my fucking...
Eastie outfit!
No!
Leave me alone.
Leave me alone!
No, don't come inside.
Don't come inside.
He's not gonna take it.
He's not gonna take my...
Mr. East outfit.
He's never gonna take...
my Mr. East outfit.
No matter what, he'll never be...
Mr. East.
Okay.
Not the neighborhood.
Watch.
No one's gonna take my...
Mr. East outfit!
Alright.
Okay.
We need to... I need to know who lives up there.
I need to know who lives up here.
Who lives up here in this mansion?
Toga!
Welcome to the...
tomato farm!
Welcome!
Who's this?
Elamzuck.
What's popping?
Like...
How can I assist you, my tech-savvy...
amigo?
Okay.
Mr. Elam.
I have a great...
idea for you for the next...
big video!
Oh wow, Mr. East.
I'm all ears.
Spill the deets.
What's this epic video idea that's gonna make...
waves in the tech world?
Okay.
Now I need to think of an actual idea.
Guys, give me a sec.
I didn't think he would actually...
ask me what the idea was.
I thought I could say that, and then he'll just...
be like, don't worry.
Here are the funds.
That's it.
Okay.
Okay, wait.
Okay, we need to think of a video idea.
A real video idea that Mr. East...
would do.
Okay.
So you know how I was buried.
Underneath for 24 hours.
Now imagine...
I was buried for 24 hours...
but with iPhones.
Mr. East, that sounds...
interesting.
But I'm not quite sure how...
burying yourself with an iPhone would be the next big thing.
Thanks for sharing my brain.
I can't invite you in the moment.
But this...
with iPhones!
It's with an iPhone!
That's the next big thing!
That's the new thing!
Like...
imagine all the free advertising...
for iPhone.
Hello there, Mr. East.
What brings you to my doorstep...
at this ungodly hour?
Okay.
Congratulations, Karen!
I will need you...
to be in my next...
Mr. East video.
Oh well, isn't that just thrilling?
But before I make my grand debut...
I'll need to know all the details.
Who else will be featuring...
alongside me?
Okay, who else?
Who's the other...
uh...
stopiplier?
Stopiplier?
I don't know.
Markiplier?
What?
What is this world's Markiplier?
Who is this world's Markiplier?
Markiplier?
Regina...
Elon Musk...
Elon Zuck?
Elon Zuck said...
that he would like to be in this video.
Imagine being in a video...
with Elon Zuck, Karen!
Elon Zuck?
Seriously?
That's not...
What do you mean?
I just talked to him!
Being in some...
silly video with...
He was real, Karen!
He's real to me!
He was real to me!
I can't believe it!
I swear he exists!
Someone will be in my Mr. East video!
Who's this?
Well, well, well.
Look who 5 decides to leave his mom's basement.
What brings you to the real world, Mr. YouTube Sensation?
Do you find out...
Excuse you, I am Mr. I'm not even gonna talk to her.
Look at this.
If she doesn't understand the importance of Mr. East, then she does not deserve to be eaten.
Hello, Mr. There, Mr. East.
It's positively delightful to see you at such an hour.
How simply splendid!
What brings you to my humble abode, good sir?
You wanna be in my Mr. East video?
Oh my, what an honor to be in your Mr. East video!
I simply cannot contain my excitement!
Count me in, dear sir!
To be in my Mr. East video, I need you to sign a contract to make sure we are not liable for your safety.
Is that okay?
Oh dear, a contract?
That sounds absolutely terrifying!
I'm afraid I just can't handle the stress!
I must bid you good farewell, good sir!
But what about my Mr. East video?
What do you mean?
No one wants to be in my Mr. East video!
Please, what do you want, Mr. East?
Can't you see I'm already drowning in the depths of my blackest desire?
Do you wanna be in my Mr. East video?
Who would sign a restrictive contract?
Are you serious?
You think I wanna be part of your mainstream sellout video?
No thanks!
I'll stick to my underground edgy scene!
Okay, but Fallout Roy, this video is for the underground edgy scene!
We're making it different!
Really?
Well, if it's really gonna be unique and true to the spirit of the underground scene, then maybe I'll consider it, but don't expect me to sell my soul or compromise my artistic integrity!
Okay, fuck, okay.
Any like, artistic people here?
Who won't compromise their artistic integrity?
What do they like?
I'm a... I'm a VTuber, I'm willing to compromise my artistic integrity!
Okay.
Alright.
Fuck.
Okay, I, um...
You know what, Roy?
Because I like your style, I'll even give you creative control!
Wait, seriously?
Creative control?
That's like the dream, man!
Alright, you've piqued my interest, I'll let you in.
But only because you seem to understand the importance of artistic freedom.
Come on, what the fuck, it was that easy?
Okay, I'm gonna kill this guy now.
I'm in!
This is so mainstream!
Holy shit!
That was actually the easiest!
That's all it took!
That's really...
That's really all it took!
I just went like, yeah...
Artistic integrity...
Was it really that easy?
Apparently, all they care about is artistic integrity.
I can't believe it.
Don't get scammed.
Oh my god!
Influencers and artists!
Please!
Love yourself more!
Okay, let me...
Now I look...
I look fancy.
Oh, it's Karen.
Oh my gosh, what fabulous surprise!
Are you here to give me a sneak peek of the new spring collection?
Or maybe spill some...
Oh no, I'm not.
I don't wanna talk.
I already went through Regina.
I don't wanna go through another Regina.
I'm so done.
Oh my god, wait, that's my shirt!
My shirt!
No more tea!
I'm so done with tea, guys.
I've had...
I've had enough fill of tea.
Chat.
Regina trauma.
Hello?
Oh shit, this is Tommy.
You're the most fabulous I've seen all day.
How about we hit the town and strut your...
Okay.
Bro, are they all fashion people?
Please!
I don't wanna deal with fashion!
I'm so over it!
I'm so fucking over fashion right now.
I'm so done.
I don't wanna gossip anymore.
Oh my god!
A fellow enthusiast of scientific...
...eccentry.
Welcome, welcome.
What brings you to my lair...
...at this ungodly hour?
As a fellow scientist...
...I've heard about your research...
...all the way from Canada.
Canada?
Fuck, okay.
What has he done?
Does anyone know what pinky brains have done?
Does anyone know?
The jetpack!
Obviously the jetpack.
No one has been able to successfully jetpack ever.
You are the first one, sir.
The jetpack!
A marvel of modern science indeed.
But I must admit, my dear friend, the jetpack is just the tip of the iceberg in my grand pla- What?
How do you fucking do world domination with a fucking jetpack?
It's a jetpack.
It's literally like you fly.
You can't dominate anything with- whatever.
This scientist ain't so bright, actually.
Of course!
Oh my god, you know what?
You're right.
Fuck the world.
I just said that.
Oh!
It seems you're feeling rather- Distraught.
Tries his best, we postpone- What do you mean?
World!
What?
He was gonna dominate the world!
Okay.
You had him.
I blew it!
So, world domination?
You caught it to my grand ambition, I see.
Yes!
World domination?
You caught it to my grand ambition, I see.
Yes!
World domination is my ultimate goal!
With my brilliant mind and impeccable sense of style, nothing can stand in my way!
Okay.
Okay, we're back here.
I don't know why he didn't question why I just said world domination.
But that's okay.
We're back in it.
He wants to dominate, not destroy.
Okay.
Oh yeah, you're right.
So...
World domination and change.
Was that even real?
How dare you mock my craft- What?
Leave me at once before I unleash my fashionable fear.
What do you mean?
I should never...
I don't know why.
You know, this is your fault.
Whoever...
Whoever's idea that was to say world domination and chill?
That was on you.
That was your fault!
Alright, I got an idea.
Okay.
Hello.
I come in peace, but also...
world domination?
Ah, fellow mastermind with ambitions for world domination!
I must say, your sense of style and choice of accessories do intrigue me.
Pray tell, what diabolical plans do you have in mind?
Well, fellow earthling...
My alien friends and I are planning on abducting the president.
How dare you suggest such a...
I will not be part of your misguided attempt to disrupt world order.
You are...
Leave at once!
What do you want?
Your world domination!
If you don't want...
How are you supposed to do world...
Okay.
I'm just gonna ask him.
I need to know what his plans are.
Now I'm confused.
Now I'm fucking confused.
Why the...
I don't know!
What else do you do for world domination?
Simba!
What are your plans for world domination?
Frivollaughing Oh, my dear time-traveling friend.
World domination is indeed my ultimate goal.
My plan involved...
Jetpack doki!!
You don't understand!
It's all about the jetpack.
Simba laughter My plans involve harnessing the power of Mind Control...
How is that wor- How is that better than abducting the president?
Like, how is that better?
Shouldn't that be worse?
Like...
Okay, just say yes.
Alright.
Yes.
And it was that easy.
All I had to say was yes.
He just wanted the yes man.
Oh my god.
Alright, let's see what love bites is.
I need to know what love-
Deliver breakup letter and give them advice.
Watch the drama you caused unfold.
Just keep saying yes.
Alright, let's break some hearts.
Wait, that's fun.
Alright.
Who are we?
Grandma Maude.
Alejandro.
Jay Gatsby.
Wait, oh my god, what the fu- Hahaha!
Okay, who is- who is- what the fuck- beast?
Oh my god, okay, the beast.
What do you want, festival creature?
Stop bothering me and my bell.
Bell told me you're ugly in the beast form.
How dare I have no time for your lies!
Leave me and my bell alone!
No!
Okay.
You're more like listening to someone that you don't like.
You don't trust and like, I'm likeable!
Hahaha!
Okay, wait.
Okay.
Okay, wait, this is it.
Alright.
We can do this.
Okay.
What do you want, human?
Can't you see I'm trying to enjoy this dreadful party?
Okay.
I heard from the grapevine that...
Bell was talking to Gusto.
Guston.
I heard from the grapevine that Bell was talking to Guston.
Hahaha!
How dare you spread such lies about Bell!
Leave once before- What?!
Okay.
Fuck, okay.
Okay, maybe- Oh!
Oh, I have an idea!
I have an idea.
I'll just- I'll like- I'll like, riz him up a little bit so I'm more believable.
He's so loyal!
Get that flashy package out before I turn into confetti.
Hey, you're looking pretty good today, beast!
Flatter won't save you from the rap-y gun sauce!
Oh my god, he only has eyes for one person.
And it's only Bell.
Where's Bell?
Maybe Bell is easier to trick.
Hahaha!
Where's Bell?
Where the fuck is Bell?
Maybe all I have to do is trick Bell.
He's loyal!
Hahaha!
Oh my- Why is he so loyal?!
Where the fuck is Bell?
Wait, does the police officer have like- Frank?
Oh hey Frank, who's- move along, citizen.
Where's- Where's Bell?
It can't be- Be gone, wench!
Hahaha!
There's- I only have eyes for one person.
Where the fuck is- Where the fuck is Bell?
I can't find her!
Where is she?
Hahaha!
Where the fuck is- is she?
There's Mr. Darcy?
Get her to leave, it's easier.
I know I'm trying to find Bell!
Hahaha!
There's Prince Char- Oh there she is!
There she is!
Okay.
Oh la la, bonjour, monsieur!
What delightful surprise!
May I ask what lovely gift you bring to this- Okay.
You're looking so wonderful in that dress.
Oh merci, monsieur!
Your words are as sweet as a French macaron!
Do you dance the salsa as beautifully as you compliment, perhaps?
Okay, um...
Um...
Oui, mademoiselle?
Would you care to have a dance with me?
Oh how f- Oh how f- Bro!
She's- What the fuck?
The beast has eyes for one person.
But Bell...
Bell is willing to dance with me!
She ain't so innocent as we thought she was!
Hahaha!
The beast deserves better!
Fuck, okay, what do we tell her?
Hahaha!
She's for the streets.
Oh my god!
Alright.
Hahaha!
Madame, did I ever tell you how beautiful you look?
In the moonlight?
Oh monsieur!
Your words are like sonnets set in the romantic light of the moon!
What a charming heart you have!
Tell me, do you truly believe such words?
Or do you simply have the tongue of a silvered serpent?
Oh my god!
Beast, you deserve so much better!
Why, mademoiselle, of course I speak the truth.
You are the most beautiful woman I've seen tonight.
Hahaha!
Oh monsieur, your words warm my heart like a cozy fire on a winter eve.
Tell me, do you see me as more than just a pretty face in this dazzling ballroom?
Of course, mademoiselle.
It's not just your looks, but your brain as well.
You are truly an intellectual.
Hahaha!
Oh!
Pardon, monsieur, but your words ring hollow like an empty carriage.
What use is flattery if it falls upon ears already worried?
I must take my leave now.
No!
I was so close!
Hahaha!
No!
I choked!
She doesn't like to be complimented about her brain?
Question mark?
She doesn't like to be said that she's smart?
Hahaha!
The word brain is not romantic.
I will save the beast.
Oh my god.
I can't believe brain isn't considered romantic.
Okay.
Where do you find such fabulous attire?
Um.
I was inspired by you, Belle!
You're looking gorgeous tonight!
Hahaha!
Oh, you're too kind, mon ami.
Merci beaucoup!
Do tell me, did you learn any dance moves for tonight's celebration?
Okay, I can try this again.
Of course!
And can I kindly ask you to be my dance partner tonight?
Oh la la!
You just dance with me just like that, Belle?
Bro, he's right there!
Belle!
He's right there!
Hahaha!
Oh, Freda, welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Um.
Okay.
Yes, of course, mademoiselle!
Let me sweep you off your feet!
Mandeux!
You are so charming!
I cannot wait to dance with you, but tell me, have you always been such a smooth salsa dancer?
Um.
Fuck, okay.
Hahaha!
We all had to start somewhere, but you, Belle, you inspire me to improve, mon ami!
Oh, how sweet of you to say!
Delightful to have inspired you!
Tell me what motivates you the most in your salsa dancing journey?
Um.
My motivation is please stop!
Hahaha!
This feels like a job interview!
Okay.
No, I'm not gonna fumble it!
I am not gonna fumble it this time!
Hahaha!
Okay.
Um.
What motivates you the most in your salsa dancing journey?
When I close my eyes, mon ami, I imagine being able to dance with you in the future, just like today!
Hahaha!
Well, words are like poetry, monsieur!
I imagine our future dances together fill my heart with joy!
Let's continue dancing and dreaming together, shall we?
Why, of course, monsieur!
Take my hand!
Hahaha!
Enchant!
Let's dance our hearts out, mon ami!
Bro, he's like right there!
Yeah!
He's like right there!
I can't!
Just say yes!
Oui, madem...
Oui, belle!
Hahaha!
Oui, oui, belle!
No!
Ah oui!
Let's twirl and roll with passion and grace, monsieur!
Our dance is like a beautiful story unfolding before our eyes!
Okay!
Oui, oui!
Okay, okay, we have to...
Okay, we have to make her break up with Mr. Beast.
Mr. Beast!
Belle, we can't!
This is forbidden!
You have to end it with hit-miss!
With the Beast, if we have, we can be together!
Okay, is that...
Do you think I'm... Do you think we're at the stage where she will break up with the Beast?
Do you think we're at that stage?
Do you think?
Hahaha!
No?
Belle, what do I say?
Too far?
Not yet!
What do I say, though?
Too fast?
Belle, do you feel the same way I do about you?
Hahaha!
Your question brings a cloud of doubt!
If only I could be completely sure!
I need to be a moment!
No!
Belle, no!
We were so close!
Belle, please!
Break up with him!
What's so just is delivery driver!
Okay.
Mon ami, I have a package for you.
Hahaha!
Excusez-moi, but I do not recall any packages.
I must bid you a...
But you had the plus!
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
We were so close!
We were so fucking close!
Keep it simple and true.
The fumble!
Belle, please!
Leave him!
What a surprise to see you here at the Valentine Park dressed as a therapist!
What secrets do you hope to recover, mon ami?
Okay.
As your therapist, I wanted to ask you if you are okay.
Hahaha!
Oh la la!
I'm touched by your concern, Monsieur Therapist.
I'm quite alright.
Just a little bored with the lack of excitement in my life.
Do you have any thrilling stories to share with you?
No.
Okay.
For like, this breaks all confidentialities between patient and therapist.
And also I'm pretty sure like, it's very illegal for a therapist to like, try to date their patients too.
So, anyway.
Um.
Well, I have an exciting story to tell you.
I think...
I think I have a crush.
On one of my clients.
Oh la la!
A forbidden love story between therapist and client?
Quelle intrigue!
Tell me more about this mysterious amour that's captured your heart, Monsieur Therapist.
The tea!
She wears a...
She wears a crown and a beautiful white dress.
But...
She's taken by another beast.
Hello!
This tale of unrequited love touches my heart.
Have you tried discussing your feelings with someone you trust, Monsieur...
Monsieur Therapist?
This is illegal.
It's yellow?
It's white!
What do you mean?
It's the lighting!
It's the lighting.
Yes.
Yes, this is why I told you.
I trust you a lot, Belle.
Oh la la!
I am honored, but I must admit I'm feeling a tad flustered by the weight of your feelings.
Perhaps we should focus on helping you navigate this delicate situation first.
Fuck, okay.
Okay, okay.
What do you think I should do about this unrequited love?
Perhaps expressing your feelings honestly, yet respectfully, could lead to resolution, resolution, n'est-ce pas?
Okay.
Um...
Yes.
No!
It not be time to have a catty with the object you're first.
And as for me, I realize that it might be time to write a letter of my own to my own beast.
No!
Wait.
It has come that my therapist has a crush on a client who is taken by another beast.
Making me realize it's time for me to go on my own goodbye dear.
Oh wait!
That worked!
I made her realize...
I did it!
Wait!
That doesn't make sense!
I did it though!
I did it!
I just said yes!
Oh my god!
Okay.
It has a crush on me.
She was taken by another...
Making me realize it's time for me to go on my own adventure.
Hey, I know you're having a great time dancing.
But here's a letter.
Hello, I'm from...
Because some crush you have on Tal who is with another beast.
I think it's not fair what she did to you.
And demanded explanation for her actions.
Is that it?
Hello, I'm from...
You've been so distant and cold lately.
I can't take it anymore.
I think it's not fair what she did to you.
But now I think we should break up.
I can't do this anymore.
Break up?
Fine!
I saw the way you were eyeing that enchanted teapot.
And don't think I didn't notice that...
Oh my god!
I just want to thank them for the hard work.
But now I think we should...
For a teapot?
Please, I am done with this nonsense.
I don't want to be with someone who can't appreciate a good fairytale romance.
Fine, be that way.
I'll just be...
Go back to the castle and sulk with Lumiere and Cogsworth.
At least they understand me.
Goodbye, Bella.
Yay, I did it.
I did it.
Yay, a happy ending.
Mrs. Potts?
A teapot?
What the fuck?
Yay!
No love for you.
Look, he's dancing though.
He seems to be having a good time dancing.
Are you okay?
Are you okay, Beast?
What did I just witness?
I don't know.
I should have just said yes earlier.
I feel like just saying yes just solves all my problems.
See what I thought.
He's dancing his pain away.
Oh my god.
I didn't realize all I had to do was say yes.
That's all.
I think that's a good way to call it.
I think that's a good way.
Freaking out.
Beauty and the Beast.
I did it!
I will never trust a therapist anymore.
Luv, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
With the power of yes.
That's really all it took, guys.
Just keep saying yes.
What the fuck?
It's so much better than Twilight.
Just... yes.
That was fun though.
So, that was really really fun.
I don't know what...
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
That was...
That was actually so fucking funny though.
But that...
I actually did not expect how fun it was to just mess around with chat...
to mess around with chat GPT slash AI and just fucking...
The type of conversations...
The type of conversations we have with AI.
But yeah, that was... I hope you guys enjoyed that.
I know some of you were asking if I figured out my Pal World Twitch Rivals team.
I have not, except for...
Shrek.
Shrek 4...
I asked Shrek 4 if he wanted to join me because...
He really really likes Pal World.
So, that is the only teammate I have confirmed right now.
That is the only teammate I have confirmed in Pal World.
For those who are wondering what is the tournament going to be like...
It's like... It's basically like an achievement run thing.
So, they're going to give us like a list of achievements.
And then we're supposed to...
We're supposed to like try and see how many achievements we can get done in like two days basically.
So, it's going to be very interesting because I was like...
Oh, wow, Pal World Twitch Rivals.
How the fuck that's going to work?
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But yes, I have no confirmations on who else will be my teammates.
I haven't really looked at like people who asked yet.
I really haven't looked on my Twitter thread.
So, I'll figure that out later.
Also!
Also, I'm really excited about the charity auction.
Because there's a lot of like amazing talented creators that wanted to like...
Wanted to like help out and work with me on collabing on some one of a kind Doki items.
We actually had like...
I was talking about this on the chat... the waiting room chat.
But basically like I grew up with watching...
Not grew up, sorry.
I loved watching like...
Custom doll customization.
Like those who like customize like...
You know...
Um...
What is it called?
The...
Fuck!
What is that?
Like the Monster High...
Monster High!
Like those that did like Monster High dolls and stuff.
And they customize Monster High dolls to like make it look into like different things.
Like I used to watch a lot of Doll Life and stuff like that.
So, um...
A custom doll maker actually reached out to me.
And said they'll make a...
Yeah, ball jointed dolls.
Like they'll make...
They want to make a custom Doki ball jointed doll to sell for the auction.
Which is...
Um...
Which will be really fun.
And I'm really looking forward to that too.
Um...
So there's a lot...
A lot of amazing talent.
There's a lot of plushy makers.
A lot of like figure makers.
And like a lot of like talented artists that wanted to like...
Do some one of a kind items and stuff to sell at an auction.
Um...
Anyway guys...
Uh...
I am gonna call it here.
I would love to do like a super chat reading right now.
But because I have a second stream...
I want to relax a little bit.
Before the second stream.
And I'll read the super chats on the second stream.
But thank you everybody for coming!
To the first stream!
I am doing Batman later.
So if you guys want more...
Um...
I'll be...
I'll be streaming part two of Batman!
I want to do like a little bit of a long stream for Batman.
Because I think I want to try and finish the game by this week.
Um...
So by like the end of the week I...
I'll...
I'll have Batman done.
But yes, thank you everybody for calling.
I hope you guys had a great time watching!
As always everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me...
Head to bed!
Because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!